like where did the concept of the
calorie come from and it actually
originated was not it was in physics and
engineering it had nothing to do with
nutrition
but you know i take people through that
that adventure but eventually we get to
this place of like where did it become
so popularizing our culture as this
powerful dot it's the dominant metric to
manage
and it was thanks to a woman named dr
lulu hunt peters in the earlier part
like the 1900s and she had a massive
bestseller
that
essentially was
regarding the key key to the calories
right and she's really creating this
uh in a sense this this very powerful
uh paradigm that if you can control
calories you can control your weight
and sidebar for her as well she
struggled with her weight
for her entire life it did not fix her
problem by the way but here's the thing
so it came into culture and it was
telling people specifically she's more
so speaking to women
that
we will no longer eat food you will now
eat calories of food
and
from that you will no longer eat a slice
of bread you'll eat 100 calories of
bread you'll no longer eat a slice of
pie you'll eat 350 calories of pie
so we're changing this very complex the
human body is the most dynamic
entity in the known universe you know
michio kaku
theoretical physicist said the human
brain is the most complicated object in
the known universe
and we're now taking this very powerful
it's not a calculator with calories it's
really a glorified
laboratory and chemistry
set in environment and now we're just
saying if you could do this one thing
you're going to get these results so
um
that's where the next idea
as an example of something i found
fascinating one of the tests i've done
was i used a continuous blood glucose
monitor for a month and
whenever i would be stressed and like
had a conversation that was heated or
something like that
uh my blood sugar would go up i didn't
even need anything
yeah it's like an example of how
complicated this system is that there's
like a million overlapping things in the
body that go oh no you can't just do
this one thing and have the other things
not matter
so the fact that they're trying to use
one
metric which i've even thought about the
metric of a calorie like how do you
calculate it right like i know that
there's i think there's some sort of
like bunsen burners program that you put
things through
and get some kind of metric right but
i'm like
that's not what they're doing what a
calorie was
you're right that's but they're not
doing that today so it's a bomb
calorimeter was what was used initially
to
disseminate how many calories are in a
particular substance but it was never
accurate it would never was because it
didn't
account for indigestible parts of food
for example basically to put into
um you know a container that goes inside
of another container it's filled with
water then use electrical energy to burn
the food incinerated and then you like
the
that's what you used to measure how many
calories were there
it's so you're this is the thing you're
not a bomb calorimeter you're a human
being by the way number one number two
this is not what's used in
in counting how many calories are in
your food which is based on the atwater
system which again we could take time
and break down all what that means
basically they're just doing math food
manufacturers are just doing math and
putting it on the food label
so but still it can give us it's not to
say that a calorie can't be a viable
tool that we utilize but we've made the
calorie the king of nutrition and look
where it's got us
there are going to be some people that
like well i've used calorie management
and it's helped me
that's great it's going to help people
but when we make that the dominant thing
and ignore what i'm about to share
that's where things go dramatically
wrong and our society's results are
sharing that with 252 million citizens
in the united states right now are
overweight or obese and there's like
320 million in the country
it's insane it's like beyond epidemic
proportions and so here's what's going
on so here's a couple of things these
are epic or controllers these are things
that actually control what calories do
in your body
all right so and i'm and i'm so grateful
to be able to say this but my and to be
able to talk with you about it because
you really understand but bruce lipton
was my inspiration for creating the term
epicoloric
and so these are controllers
above caloric control these are what
these are things that control what
calories do in your body so one of them
is your brain and neural inflammation
your brain controls what calories do in
your body have a massive influence
on your digestion and assimilation and
so a recent report this was published in
the annals of the new york academy of
sciences
and it reported that hypothalamic
inflammation so this is inflammation
regarding the hypothalamus that is a
integrator of your endocrine system your
hormones and your nervous system your
neurotransmitters
and so they said that this inflammation
in the hypothalamus which is
probably the biggest
epidemic happening right now that people
don't know about we'll talk about why
is a double-edged sword in nutritional
diseases the study authors reported that
systemic inflammation from things like
metabolic dysfunction right so
diabetes for example
that issue in it of itself
metabolic dysfunction and excessive body
fat leads to brain inflammation
all right so carrying body fat creates
inflammation in the hypothalamus
and inflammation of the hypothalamus
creates excessive body fat
and metabolic dysfunction
so we get into this vicious circle
and essentially
your brain you have the your vagus nerve
that's connecting the gut and the brain
for example and i talk about this in
each one as well but essentially there's
this constant
light speed feedback loop
with your gut and that which is also
called the enteric nervous system or the
second brain because it's there's like a
mass of neural tissue
in the gut itself there's more we have
more neurotransmitters in our gut than
we do in our brain isn't that is that am
i reporting um is that good information
or bad information
the brain the brain has the most okay
but the second most is is found in that
yes and even the heart as well has its
own that we call it the heart brain has
there's a significant amount of of
neural tissue very similar to what's in
the brain in our heart as well but
that's a whole other thing so here's
here's what happens so there's this
constant feedback loop taking place
and based on the assessment
between your brain and your gut on how
much energy you have stored in your body
what nutrients you need
your brain can actually signal your gut
to shut down the absorption of calories
from your food or increase the
absorption of calories from your food
all right based on your overall
metabolic assessment of what you have
in your body so
theoretically just say you eat 100
calories of something your with the
information your brain your gut has it
can tell your body like oh we only need
50 of those calories
and this is not accounted for in
conventional caloric management
equations that your brain and your gut
can literally determine and dysfunction
with them can determine
how many calories you're absorbing are
not absorbing and this goes back to
hormones with again if there's
resistance there's leptin resistance or
insulin resistance and your body thinks
that you're starving even though you've
got a tremendous amount of fat stored in
your body
right
this is where we can have an increased
assimilation of calories from the same
food that another person might eat and
they're not even absorbing as much
so that's number one and i'll just share
it like two two more but i go through
and talk about really there's seven of
these epic caloric controllers that we
identify but one of them is neural
inflammation another one how do we
reduce it then like can you give us a
little like uh some sure nice just like
for each one of you that's what we can
do because it's one thing to know it's
another thing to have a call to action
yes i like you're amazing all right so
this is so this was done by researchers
at auburn university all right and i'm
this is not an advocation for what they
shared but the data exists and it's
fascinating
so what they discovered was that
oleokanthal rich extra virgin olive oil
is able to actually repair
the blood-brain barrier
and to decrease brain inflammation
all right and it just it is what it is
because of the the blood-brain barrier
is this protective system for the brain
the brain has its own specific diet we
call it neural nutrition a lot of stuff
isn't able to enter the brain but as the
blood-brain barrier is broken down
through
toxicants
abnormal things that we bring in through
our nutrition
stress can break down that blood-brain
barrier
and so to help to regenerate and to heal
it funny enough and again i wasn't the
biggest fan of olive oil but i was like
this is that's incredible to be able to
have that kind of effect on the brain
like that's remarkable so what the
researchers found was two to three
tablespoons a day
uh appears to be very therapeutic in
healing and assisting in reducing neural
inflammation and that's one i mean i
could again we could spend the whole
time no that's great just something that
people can do
i mean doesn't the brain the brain feeds
off of fat right isn't that one of the
one of the things that makes the brain
operate
um
so much human brain it is it is fat it's
primarily fat if we're talking about the
dry weight the brain is primarily water
by the way so we're talking about
somewhere in the ballpark of 80 water
which is another solution if we're
talking about inflammation or fire
water
would be an important attribute here but
most people in our society are walking
around walking around with dehydrated
brains
so
taking water out of the equation the
brain is primarily fat but we got to go
deeper than that what kind of fat
because not all fats are able to
actually enter the brain and pass the
blood-brain barrier so cholesterol is
one of the primary fats the brain is
made of
we've got sphingolipids another one as
well phospholipids
uh we've got sphingomyelin you know i
can go on and on and break these down
and there's certain foods that provide
the building blocks
that are able to actually cross the
blood vessels eat smarter is the
information in each smarter your book
most of it is
but even in the chapter we talk about
cognitive health and brain health i
couldn't put everything that i know in
the data in there but also i do talk
about it on my show quite a bit like i
got mastered yeah oh yeah yeah the fats
of the brain and scientists and things
are always emerging and that's a
beautiful thing about wellness is we
just keep learning so okay olive oil
love it a couple of tablespoons a day
will help with the blood brain barrier
and help you with uh with inflammation
love it
yes so another one of these epicolor
controllers
and this is one of the biggest takeaways
from today because it's affirming
something that we might say
or a belief that we might carry about
nutrition but now we have solid science
to affirm
this factor and another controller of
what calories actually do in your body
is the type of food itself
so people might say all calories are not
created equal now we have the data so
this study was published in food and
nutrition research
and they set out to find
whether or not there's a difference in
calories absorbed assimilated in
metabolic function
from eating a meal of whole foods versus
a meal of processed foods right and so
in the experiment
what they used was a whole food sandwich
which again i'm not this is not about
whether or not this is
the best source of whole foods but this
is what they did it was a whole food
sandwich which included a whole grain
bread and cheddar cheese and then they
had test subjects to consume a processed
food sandwich which was made of white
bread and cheese product with cheese
product that's what craft is by the way
we grew up on
yes so it's not you can't legally even
call it cheese you know it's clap craft
singles because it's not enough amazing
what our body will be it's amazing the
resilience that our body has that we can
feed it you know
fruit roll-ups and gushers
and
you know uh
craft singles golden grahams golden yeah
golden fit goldfish
and pockets we still grow to babies you
know we still keep getting taller and we
still keep getting smarter it's really
amazing
the human body is incredibly resilient
to say the least you know but just
imagine what happens when we really get
on the good stuff and what our genes are
expecting and so
here's what happened so they gave
folks you know to see again what how do
calories react in their bodies when
eating a meal of whole foods or a meal
of processed foods
and so what they discovered was that
when the test participants
ate the processed food sandwich they had
a 50
reduction
in calorie burn after consuming that
sandwich versus when they ate the meal
of whole foods
okay so the processed version of these
foods which were very abnormal not
really anything that the human body can
even recognize as food
it created what i call essentially these
hormonal clogs
that created dysfunction and disruption
in the body's processing of those
calories making the body more stingy and
hanging on to that caloric energy and
not in a sense not really knowing what
to do with it
you know versus when they ate the more
whole food version of it it was more
efficient in the expenditure of that of
those calories so truly the type of food
matters so when we have these different
diets again they can be effective but if
it's a point system diet for example and
it's not paying attention to the quality
of the food we're shooting ourselves in
the foot and you got to look at the even
the people who are promoting them you
know oftentimes they continue to
struggle with their weight and we're
just like oh whatever
whatever you know it's it's my fault
it's my fault i'm not making the point
system work for me it's my fault that
i'm not counting the calories
adequately enough like i gotta i gotta
cut em more i gotta cut them harder i've
had patients come in who are eating
under a thousand calories a day and
their weight will not so hard to do
we're working with you know their quote
weight loss
doctor
and they come in they're they're just
metabolically broken and they've created
a state of learned helplessness where
they think it's their fault like they're
just not trying hard enough yeah and not
under not getting this education on
here's how your body and these
your hormones and your organs and your
fat loss related
processes here's how it all works let's
get you well let's heal these systems